there is a really bizarre and sad story
out of did you know it was earth day
last week it was earth day i totally
missed it i don't know that that wasn't
marked off on my liturgical calendar but
i guess it was earth day
a man
burned himself to death a man committed
suicide by lighting himself on fire at
the supreme court
to protest
air pollution
to protest
what he thinks is global warming
this man when bruce it was a 50 year old
climate activist
and he was taken to a local hospital
after he set himself on fire and then he
died
of his of his injuries
he he's obviously was obviously a
mentally disturbed man who committed
suicide this is this is a sad story we
should all feel bad about but some of
his friends don't think that you should
feel bad about that there is one guy a
zen buddhist priest an environmental
scientist dr k kriti who said this guy
was my friend he meditated with our
sangha this act is not suicide this is a
deeply fearless act of compassion to
bring attention to the climate crisis so
first of all it was suicide when you
kill yourself that's suicide by
definition
this
buddhist dude or the climate guy who
killed himself they can try to justify
suicide they're not going to be
successful at that because suicide is
not justifiable but
regardless it is suicide you at a
certain point you do have to call a
spade a spade that's just
what to kill yourself is to commit
suicide
there's a further irony here which is
the guy committed suicide in order to
protest fossil fuels
how do you light himself on fire
i don't know there isn't a lot of
reporting on this
in the
most famous historical examples of
people setting themselves on fire to
protest things the vietnam war for
instance
people usually
pour gasoline on themselves
so it it makes it even sadder because
probably the way this dude killed
himself was by burning up some
fossil fuels even if it were just the
plastic in his clothing
seems to be an incoherent action
to protest
fossil fuels by burning up some fossil
fuels and releasing it into the
environment and killing yourself along
the way
that is disordered stuff
again
totally outside of the political process
this guy wasn't protesting
global warming or whatever by picketing
outside of an oil company headquarters
he wasn't doing it by lobbying his
representatives in the government
he just killed him he he committed an
illegal action
he committed violence against himself it
wasn't against libs of tick-tock or some
conservative but it was against himself
he committed an act of violence because
he was so
dead set on upending the political
process for his disturbed
views i'm glad you liked that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get all those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]